Why do smart people make dumb decisions?
Why do conspiracy theorists think that we
didn’t land on the moon or that Hillary
Clinton is a space alien?
And why won’t Bernice admit that the new
Superman movie just isn’t very good?
We’ve talked about cognition before.
We usually refer to it as the process that
we use to think and solve crossword puzzles
and stuff.
But really, cognition involves knowing, remembering,
understanding, communicating, and to a certain
extent, learning.
And as truly wonderful as our brains are,
we can be spectacularly bad at ALL of these
things.
We used to think our cognition worked like
a computer -- logically processing information.
But that cabbage-sized chunk of pink, wet
brain matter in your skull can do a lot more
than math, and the things that it does are
certainly not always logical.
Many experts argue that it’s cognition that
makes us truly human, and that everything
that comes with it -- our preferences, prejudices,
fears, and intuitions -- are what make us
the individuals that we are.
We’re not the only animals that show some
evidence of cognition, of course: Chimps and
gorillas exhibit insight and planning; crows
use tools; elephants teach each other.
But our capacity as humans to figure stuff
out is matched only by our ability to totally
misjudge stuff.
As prone as we are to brilliance and insight,
we’re equally likely to succumb to irrational
thinking and false intuition.
So, to borrow a riff from Rene Descartes,
you think, therefore you are.
Which means you’re brilliant a lot of the
time.
And sometimes, you’re just going to look
stupid.
[INTRO]
We all want to make sense of the world.
And one of the major ways our cognition allows
us do that is by forming concepts -- mental
groupings of similar objects, people, ideas,
or events.
We like to lump things together.
Concepts simplify our thinking in such a fundamental
way that we usually don’t have to stop and
think about using them, they’re just there.
And yet without concepts, we’d need a unique
name for everything.
You couldn’t just ask me to shake the anglerfish
-- because there’d be no concept of shake
or fish, let alone stuffed, blue anglerfish.
And if I told you I was devastated that I
lost my anglerfish -- which I probably would
be -- I’d also have to explain my emotions,
their intensities, even the words themselves
that I had to use.
So basically, without concepts, no one would
ever get anything done.
We’d all be like a bunch of ents taking
all morning to say “Hey, what’s up?”
We often organize our concepts by forming
prototypes--mental images or pinnacle examples
of a certain thing.
For example, if I say “bird”--the general
shape of a songbird probably pops into your
head before like, a penguin or chicken or
emu, because robins and cardinals more closely
resemble our bird prototype.
Still, if I show you a picture of some crazy
creature you’ve never seen before, and you
note that it has feathers and a beak, you’ll
probably file it under the bird category because
it more closely resembles your concept of
bird than your concept of rodent or overcoat
or footstool.
Concepts and prototypes speed up our thinking,
but they also can box in our thinking, and
lead to prejudice if we see something that
doesn’t fit our prototypes.
A hundred years ago the sight of a female
doctor might have caused some heads to explode,
because in peoples’ tiny minds, the prototypes
of “doctor” and “woman” didn’t have
any overlap.
And actually some people today still feel
that way.
Haters gonna hate.
So it’s important to actively keep your
mind open mind to make room for evolving concepts,
and remember that concepts may sometimes hurt
as much as they help.
One of the biggest ways our cognition works
to our benefit, though, is through our ability
to solve problems.
We use our problem-solving skills all the
time: How to assemble Scandinavian furniture,
bake muffins with a missing ingredient, or
handle the crushing disappointment of the
new Superman movie.
And we approach problem-solving in different
ways -- sometimes we value speed; other times,
accuracy.
Some problems we figure out using trial and
error--you know, you try something and if
it doesn’t work, try it a different way,
and keep at it until something works.
Trial and error is slow and deliberate--which
may be good or bad, depending on the problem.
We can also use algorithms and heuristics
to come up with solutions.
Algorithms are logical, methodical, step-by-step
procedures that guarantee an eventual solution,
though they may be slow to work through.
Heuristics, on the other hand, are more like
mental shortcuts -- simple strategies that
allow us to solve problems faster, although
they’re more error-prone than algorithms.
Say you’re at the store, looking for a family-sized
bottle of Sriracha.
You could use an algorithm and methodically
check every shelf and aisle in the store.
Or you could use heuristics and first search
the Asian or condiment sections--the places
that make the most sense based on what you
already know.
Heuristics may be way faster, but the algorithmic
approach guarantees you won’t overlook the
sauce along the way, because they stuck it
in the deli or whatever dumb thing they did
this week.
So algorithms, heuristics, and trial-and-error
are problem-solving strategies that involve
a plan of attack.
But sometimes we get lucky while puzzling
out a problem, and Aha!, out of nowhere a
sudden flash of insight that solves our problem.
I’ll use orange in the muffin recipe instead
of lemon!
Or, Sriracha lives in the Mexican section!
For some reason!
Neuroscientists have actually watched that
kind of sudden, happy brain flash on neuroimaging
screens.
In one experiment, they gave subjects a problem
to solve:
What word can be added to the three words
CRAB, PINE, and SAUCE to create a new compound
word?
Then they asked the subjects to press a button
when they had the answer.
While the subjects thought about it, scans
showed activity in their frontal lobes, the
areas involved in the focused attention of
typical problem-solving.
But right at the Aha! moment, just as they
pushed the button, there was a clear burst
of activity just above the ear in the right
temporal lobe, which, among many other things,
is involved with recognition.
The answer, by the way, we already gave you
the hint earlier in the episode.
Where’s my fish?
Those sudden bursts of insight are awesome,
but you can’t count on them to solve all
your problems.
And just because something feels, doesn’t
mean it’s truly correct.
Because as inventive and smartypants as we
may be, our cognition often leads us astray
in all kinds of ways.
For instance, we often look for, and favor,
evidence that verifies our ideas, while we’re
more likely to avoid or ignore contradictory
evidence -- a tendency known as confirmation
bias.
This is really similar to the overconfidence
we’ve talked about, when you’re basically
more confident than you are correct.
When this kind of cognitive bias takes hold,
you might cling to your initial conceptions
in a kind of belief perseverance, even in
the face of clear proof to the contrary.
This happens all the time, and it can be maddening
for people watching it happen.
People still think that the earth is flat!
It’s like...WHAT?
HOW?
There’s space pictures!
I probably don’t need to tell you -- people
can really get weird and defensive when they
evade facts and choose to see only the information
that confirms their beliefs.
They may even become functionally fixed, unable
to view a problem from a new perspective.
Instead they just keep approaching a situation
with the same mental set, especially if it’s
worked in the past.
Say you’ve got a nail sticking out from
a board, and you’re like “I need to take
care of that!”
There’s rocks, and bricks all around you.
But because of your functional fixedness on
the idea that only hammers work on nails,
you don’t even consider hitting it with
the brick, and instead you waste a bunch of
time in the garage looking for a hammer, and
you’re angry and frustrated, and there’s
still a nail sticking up from the board.
So, our mental set predisposes how we think,
just as you’ll remember that our perceptual
set predisposes how we perceive.
This is what makes heuristics -- those super-convenient
mental shortcuts that we all use -- so easily
fallible.
In the 1970s, cognitive psychologists Amos
Tversky and Daniel Kahneman researched how
we make snap judgments, and discovered one
way smart people make dumb decisions.
They found that people believe an event will
be more likely to occur if they can conjure
up examples or memories of it, especially
if those examples are particularly vivid,
scary, or awesome.
So, say you’re in a casino and you win two
dollars at a slot machine.
Suddenly every flashing light and ringing
bell in the place goes off.
But when you lose -- which is the vast majority
of the time -- it’s just...crickets.
With all their lights and noise-making, the
casino makes sure that wins are super vivid
and memorable, while losses just go away unacknowledged.
That way, the next time you’re standing
there with 100 bucks in your pocket, you’re
more likely to overestimate your chances of
winning, because the memories of winning are
more striking.
The more mentally available those memories
are, the more it seems that it’s going to
happen again.
This is known as the availability heuristic.
And it can warp our judgements of people,
too.
If we keep remembering news footage that shows
people of a given group shooting guns, that
can shape our impression of the entire group
-- even if what we saw was only a tiny minority
within that group.
Essentially, we are great at fearing the wrong
things.
We worry about being killed in a plane crash
or getting bitten in half by a shark or accidentally
choking on a dumpling.
Thanks to our brain’s b-roll of horrific
images, we come to fear what’s actually
very rare, instead of worrying about much
more common, but less memorable ends like
car accidents, cancer, and heart failure.
Our thinking can also be swayed by framing,
or how an issue is presented.
Imagine you’re considering climbing Everest
or getting a nose job or eating a bowl of
raw blowfish.
I can frame the risks in different ways.
Telling you that you’ve got a 95 percent
chance of survival sounds a lot different
than saying five out of a hundred people die
doing this activity, though the information
is the same.
Our cognitive minds are capable of incredible
intellectual feats and tremendous failures.
We can solve problems better than any organism
on the planet, but given the chance, we can
also mess up a pretty simple judgment every
day of the week.
But if we’re mindful of our capacity for
error -- and if we honor our ingenuity and
intellect -- I think our ability to solve
any problem is nearly infinite.
And that, gives me a lot of hope.
Seriously though where is my fish?
Today you learned how we use concepts, prototypes,
and our mental sets to think and communicate,
and how algorithms, heuristics, and insight
help us solve problems.
You also learned about how fixation, the availability
heuristic, fear, overconfidence, and belief
perseverance can get in the way of good decision-making
and thinking.
Thank you for watching, especially to our
Subbable subscribers, who make this whole
channel possible.
If you’d like to sponsor an episode of Crash
Course, get a special Laptop Decal, or even
be animated into an upcoming episode, just
go to Subbable.com/crashcourse.
This episode was written by Kathleen Yale,
edited by Blake de Pastino, and our consultant
is Dr. Ranjit Bhagwat.
Our director and editor is Nicholas Jenkins,
the script supervisor is Michael Aranda, who
is also our sound designer, and the graphics
team is Thought Café.